[Music]
[Applause]
what time is
it what what what
check out figurine available now save
roll the freaking
intro dude leave your memes on the
reddit 19 year old
now measure your peeps
[Music]
that's better how felix treats edgar out
of his videos
yeah what's the problem what the hell
why is he so upvoted this is
too cute this is so adorable
oh this is so adorable felix fell asleep
hugging edgar but then edgar sneaked out
and spooned felix and said
i oh my mo huggaroo
what the hell i got what are you doing
on the floor come here oh yeah boy
yeah boy how are you doing boy look we
got
66 000 up stop sleeping we got 66 000 up
boats
you don't understand what is that why
are you so depressed
you want to hit the tambourine don't
pull the cable
you just want to sleep it's too early
all right you get to sleep
i was so confused by this uh i was like
what the hell did he go
who's hugging me here comes the second
artifact it's like poetry it rhymes
cybe okay we got slime
[Laughter]
i don't wait you might as well make a
confession video
stop pretending you're someone that
you're not that's pretty cringe
anything more cringe than being sip is
being hiding that you're a simp
yeah at least own it we have the proof
side there's no more pointed head in it
oh that's so cute
fix it for you hey guys show them how we
sleep together
huh we sleep like this huh we sleep like
this right you will never escape my hugs
[Music]
never escape my heart
[Applause]
he does not care does he look at him
he's so tired
okay stop i will go back to sleep
[Music]
he wakes me up by the way oh my god so
cute
he's laying on the
why are you so cute today he's never
this cute trust me
you have to take care of this dog he's
not cute he wakes me up at five to six
that's literally why i'm sleeping by the
way because edgar woke me up
i had to feed and walk him and then i
fell back to sleep because it was so
goddamn early
and i hear you play me like a goddamn
fiddle when you lost all your gigs cause
it pandemic but the meme king himself
listen to your music
who is this spongebob by max
that's kind of cool i love that all
right i can't play it for because the
cop were right but check out max watson
low-key want to squeeze your man bun bro
is that gay is that okay i mean
beards me i feel uncomfortable taking
selfies with fans
i know it must be tiresome thanks for
understanding
[Laughter]
no no never
no i'm a simp if i do it and i'm a
simple if i defend marzia oh god what do
i do
oh no this is what side must be like all
the time
[Music]
he better not be behind me edgar you
look so cute i'll hide the frame just so
you can see edgar's little face
sticking up because that's that's
flipping adorable
girls buying shampoo it has vitamins
did i i swear i reviewed this why is
this here for once i know i
i know for sure i reviewed this what is
happening
also cringe everyone asking me hey
pierce do you have beard oil in here no
oil is not all right we need to cancel
oil i'm sick of it
all right i said they branded it
essential oil making you think oh i
guess i need it it's going to do
no beard oil is a scam it's a goddamn
scam
so you can pretend that your beard is
important but it's not
i gotta look into the science of this
does beard oil
actually help i don't understand why you
would dish out
20 bucks for some [ __ ] drops in your
beard
explain this wait it helps growing it
bro the oil is called jojo what the [ __ ]
dude i'm in all right maybe beard all
not so bad
stop calling it essential oils why is it
called essential oil
it is not as a joke
that's like me calling g fuel
life-saving fuel huh
try out the life-saving fuel it will
save your life
because it's life-saving it's so good
check out my vital
figurine guys it's indispensable
not convinced yet check out my
indispensable figurine
i still understand listen if you can't
explain me well
what it does what it do i'm gonna assume
it does nothing
when articles about pewdiepie need a
picture yes
what year is that that has to be like
2015 or something can you not
they use that or they use some like ugly
still on me in a
from a video where i just go like
we need a photo pewdiepie let's just
take it from one of his videos that
seems fair right
people always complain about the old
images
ah screenshot there we go hey what is
this
my mom made this pewdiepie intro with
cookies
why what what is that a digi oh
oh oh oh
never stop the intros i love it so good
well done mommy song mommy pie
uh close enough oh my god
damn it no spider-man
holding the his web to stop it god damn
it's not my beard oh god my comments
maybe if you had beard oil this would be
it prevented god damn it shut up
scythe zoom in what do you see hey
a little bit of snot there's nothing
there there's nothing there
stop it stop an elaborate fan art
a female holds the drawing about
now maybe she will have sex with me
they asked me if i wanted number one but
i'm like nah
i want a fan to have number one everyone
liked that
but most importantly he wanted fans to
have 69 for 20.
yes of course i did not take those
unnumbered figurines available still how
the tables have turned
i'm back in minecraft no
swedish hot dog that is not my thumbnail
shut up i will make a thumbnail
so that this babish fella you're gonna
get it
okay this is war i'm done i make it
tamales
by the rest assured you will be making
some [ __ ] in the future
fan art for queen marzia made by me
amazing
only 30 upvotes might see holding fan
art mannered by me
let's see if this works
for us picture of me
holding fan out of marzia uh holding fat
undermines
[Music]
you know what you want use a sip
you just got that stamp i knew it sai
don't cry anymore you're not the lone
side
everybody is happy birthday
lizard love all right i'll contact
represent because
i think i think they're available if not
they're available soon uh
listed lava care package coming your way
soon wanted to draw something so the
answer is margie i start pitch maybe
next time
do you let's see if this works like they
said
20 updates just like the simulation
it works it works god damn it stop
posting fan art post you holding fan art
y'all artists you've been doing it all
wrong some things never change
oh that's so cute found this on
pinterest
pinterest it's disgusting
pinterest more like a cringe arrest
everyone cybers are simple cyber is a
sim
say that i could just edit everyone out
of the video are you really in charge
here huh
you think you can call me let's see
how dare you
no you know what that actually makes a
lot of sense because if saiv actually
was a sim
he would try and hide the fact that he
was the same like we were talking about
before
so he would edit out all the sip memes
but the fact that sai
puts the sip memes of him being a simp
n is actually kind of a chad move save
chad question mark
i'll let you decide facebook look at my
family
no look at mine youtube company sucks
yup myspace dead yep snapchat
streaks streaks i don't know what that
means instagram look
i look the prettiest i look the
prettiest reddit
my life sucks the most no mind does
twitter
i'm a [ __ ] so am i
when youtube realizes they still have to
make the rewind for this year
no simp memes it's all simp memes
youtube we won't be like yep
no no no oh my god all right
i got an email about this uh because
apparently
so i have the thousand zero one and
someone else has the zero one that's
illegal
how did this happen probably just a
photo of one of the people that worked
on the figurine with pewdiepie that was
shot prior
to them shipping the toy and the pick
was probably made for advertisers
purposes
for this site big brain systaia ross
big brain honestly the fact that someone
got it right
in the comments is pretty pretty good
actually well done
big peepy points to you to a comment i
never done that
damn all right
big peepee and tambourine salute to you
yeah that's literally
he he works at the company that produces
them
i didn't know it either though so i'm
glad it got cleared up by a big big
brain commenter
should i give away the zero one because
i have this i'm happy to have this
i don't need two of them is there a
country where where we don't ship
the figurines to let me know in the
comments
i'll reach out and you'll get my zero
one remember the blue shirt kid
is so funny though
wait does that mean blue shirt kid is
simp
no how can i unsimplifies
sacrifice three eagles bath with holy
water and live in a cave for three
months
and because we know you bells bathwater
ain't no holy water sir
damn god i'm good respect okay is this
meme he
touched pope pope touched putin putin
trump trump kim kim uh
that's south korea's president isn't it
obama
conan felix and it all
comes back oh yeah it's all coming
together
now if i could shake hand with this man
the circle will be complete
thank you sime for not cropping in on
this
amazing amazing i
was petting edgar on my lap by the way
in case anyone is wondering
i want a hot trophy wife i want all your
money want to see my yo-yo skill
see oh it's about it oh god i got it i
understand
pewdiepie is saying he doesn't want to
take selfies with his fans
me he'll never meet pewdiepie because i
live in india
understandable have nice day i gotta say
thank you guys for understanding i
wasn't sure if it was uh
it made sense or not listen you wanna
[ __ ] with me
for a couple of seconds all good just
don't want to take photos
and no i will not take photo of you and
marzia
americans trying to figure out what
month 19 is what's up
why would you start on the month it
makes no sense
honestly i think it's time america just
stops with it
with their date system the way you order
it and your
uh whatever metric system you're using
just stuff with your fahrenheit all
right it
makes no sense to use fahrenheit we all
know
it doesn't make any sense just stop from
now on
if you are caught saying fahrenheit uh
what should the punishment be
like uh we need some sort of punishment
to make people stop
shoot them that's right okay how about
that all right maybe that's about
you see a meme that uses fahrenheit
download it this is how we make a
difference
i'm tired of americans using the wrong
system this is the
first post on subreddit and my first
pewdiepie fan art
hope it goes well it's adorable oh my
god it's so cute it is cute
thank you the [ __ ] is this
stop it
oh we're so
oh cute you look beautiful today marcia
oh thank you
what the [ __ ] simp oh maya so cute
she looks so much younger
pewdiepie pledged to donate a hundred
thousand to lebanon
after massive explosion thanks to you
guys by the way it's thanks to everyone
that's a member
this is what gamers can do joe rogan i
don't think joe rogan doubts that but
[ __ ] it yeah
yeah that's right joe rogan this is what
gamer does
you know what i want to see i want to
see uh dr disrespect on joe rogan
podcast
oh god that's another one what do we got
that's right
that's god damn right that's fix that
face right there
yes dope all right so can someone please
3d print me a tambourine that fits
that'd be epic
and sunglasses that looks like
kaminasana from from tang and top uh
guern lagoon
is that too much to ask wait it's all
tambourine
wait is this part two or something
that's so dope i love it
107 million subs let's do it tambourine
keep grow
bell delphine is a marketing genius
who's using pewdiepie's cybe and us for
free publicity
yes she's using us
yeah yeah 10 million views
yeah stupid stop using a spell delphine
go away you s simp how dare you use us
for free publicity
i can't believe it how can i unsimp
myself
all right you married you gotta marry
phil delta
that's right that's what i said you're
not a sip if you get married
which makes no sense by the way if you
look at tlc
i don't know what i was thinking
cocomell and intros at the beginning
coco melons intros now yeah what is
happening i'm getting scared
every time i click on a pewdiepie video
it's like i don't know what the hell i'm
about to watch
which is weird because it's my video oh
yeah so microsoft is
possibly buying tick tock internet
explorer dead
skype did windows phone dead tick tock
i'm beginning to see a pattern here that
i'm so sure i like
i love it i like everyone that's crying
about tick tock dying
oh but this is their job to post protect
it's been live for like what
half a year it's my passion if youtube
died we all be celebrating too stop
pretending like it's so goddamn precious
pewdiepie i just posted a video it's
about so it's a gaming video
no it's not it's uh i got canceled again
it's
no way no way what the [ __ ]
did we have advanced algorithm that can
detect videos
to help
pewdiepie is saying that cybe is the
same also bell says that savage is the
same
which means that pewdiepie is helping
belle which means that
actual me wearing pewdiepie merch design
i
made see okay i need yeah
i need to just hire you guys do you want
to design it with
merch i'll pay guys let's get this on
the y so who can react to this video
yeah i think i saw a lot of these
they're really funny maybe i'll do a
reaction then because
i don't get good views though i can't
your fate has been sealed
i'm not a simp pins and hearts spells
common
you're the goddamn champion
you pinned the comment of a girl
and started it
before you lose
[Music]
amazing of course it works i thought she
drew mercy as well i was like god damn
small peepee uploaded my phone i claimed
it it was there so here's me holding my
artwork well that's how it's done and
she's fully stacked
yeah hell yeah huge peepee right there
that's how it's done ladies and
gentlemen
what a weird joke time travel invented
girls i'm gonna meet my younger self
boys
i'm gonna warn felix about his ass i
love this meme
it's just a game oh what a good meme
all right yeah i should end the video
there thank you guys for watching
thank you guys in general subscribing
checking out the merch whatever you want
to do i appreciate you
i appreciate it subscribe tower
tambourine will grow
for each subscriber well you don't care
about tower tambourine
cringe bro see you tomorrow hey though
ah children of nine parts
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean